(upbeat music)
Most places that we visit
show us only their beauty.
You opened up
and showed us your honesty.
I will give you $50 to stick
your head under this blanket.
Ew ew ew! (groans)
(laughing)
Oh, okay gang, I just got off
the phone with Carson City
and, uh, it's true
the FBI is coming in to,
uh, take a look
at the investigation.
I make my own meats.
I make my meats.
(smack)
He's a genius.
The man knits sweaters
out of human hair.
It's just got a really pretty-
Don't touch.
Don't touch the box.
An unfolding scandal has rocked
this city to its core.
Lieutenant! Lieutenant Dangle
the people have a right to know!
-Whoa!
-We got somethin'.
(gasps)
Ah!
You know what
I think it is, Jim?
I think somebody
got stabbed in the back.
You know I bet
if we'd said something,
he would have done this
in the nude.
The likeness between Craig
and the Truckee River Killer
-is eerie.
-Yeah.
But, Craig's also just one of
those little weird white people
who looks like a serial killer.
I got some great classic pieces
in here.
This is for
chopping off fingers.
I'm just kidding.
(forced laughter)
Hey guys, let me
show you this piece.
He told me that he would
cut my head off
and eat it
if I ever needed him to.
That's love.
You're probably wondering
why I'm not around.
It's ‘cause I killed a bunch
of people!